we're gonna go through this again and if
you've got your two colors at the ready
which angle are they interested in angle
a so I'm just gonna mark that in and I
can see the side that's opposite it is
53 very good so that's gonna match up
and then you've got another angle
another side 21 degrees and 37 units
centimeters who knows okay so now that I
know what matches with what I'm gonna
write the sine rule sine of angle a
divided by what again 53 very good
equals sign of the other angle 21 on the
other side 37 so far so good I multiply
through at this point you're gonna have
to reach for your calculator
what is your calculator say give me some
decimal places sets alien
really
our point five chief carry one more dr.
dot okay by the way I don't I didn't
know what the answer was but as soon as
someone said one point something I knew
something was wrong
I'll let you have a think you can ask me
later on how I knew that that couldn't
be right
zero point something is what I'm
expecting okay now usually my next line
I'm going to say angle a equals okay but
I want you to go to your calculator
what's the next step you go shift sign
right well it's to display and what do
you get
what do you get said Ian thirty point
eight eight six dot dot dot okay now
you'll notice I'm writing this in red on
purpose when we ended this question got
forty four point five I asked you to do
a sense check yeah do a sense check on
this answer for me have a look check out
the diagram thirty point eight eight six
31 degrees what's going wrong well how
do I know something is wrong 31 degrees
is is quite small right 31 degrees and
it's opposite this angle sorry this side
over here that doesn't look right
okay so what could it be instead this is
actually thinking back to our review
questions this is the base angle it's
not it's not a it's the angle that's
related to a and it looks obtuse right
in fact if you look at the top of
question three in the text it says angle
a is obtuse so therefore to get the
obtuse version of this I'm going to do
180 takeaway angle a is 180 take away
that eight eight six okay this is going
to give you some decimal places what is
that a hundred and forty nine point
something one one four one three
whatever the pot now look at the
question questions we look at the texts
they want you to do some approximation
what kind
nearest minute so at this point with the
answer still in your display you want to
hit the degrees minutes seconds button
and you're going to get a hundred and
forty nine degrees in some number of
minutes what's the next number just six
just six is the next number after that
going to make it round up to seven or is
it just gonna stay at six is it round II
what's the next number fifty well there
are only 50 seconds in a minute sorry
there are only 60 seconds in a minute so
50 is clearly up right so that will
round up to seven minutes okay so be
watchful for that they will tell you hey
look at this diagram or they'll even
just say without a diagram hey angle a
is obtuse so therefore that's not a
truce it's just the base angle does that
make sense